wow das ist wirklich eine neue dimension
gezielt suchen nach raumschiffen und
hinterlassenschaften von außerirdischen
zivilisationen das neue galileo projekt
des astrophysikers app sucht nach
physischen objekten umso außerirdisches
leben endlich dingfest zu machen unter
anderem auch mit hilfe von künstlicher
intelligenz wie genau wird diese
systematische suche nach physischen
beweisen für außerirdisches aussehen und
wie groß sind die chancen dass wir so
tatsächlich außerirdisches leben
ausfindig machen können klick zum
science im futures dreimal pro woche
spannender science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivität locke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts sie
[Musik]
haben sich gekommen das ist ein riesen
aufschlag für die astrophysik und
überhaupt für die große suche nach
außerirdischem leben und das vom
renommierten harvard astrophysiker
premnitz sein projekt galileo mit dem
man nach physischen beweisen für
außerirdische zivilisation und
technologien verhandeln will und das
ganz systematisch dazu sagt der us
astrophysiker professor bailey lasst uns
einfach starten und jeden fisch fang den
wir finden und dazu gehören erdnahe
objekte die in unserer atmosphäre
schrieben oder objekte die von außerhalb
des sonnensystems kamen und seltsam
aussehen drei hauptziele wurden nun für
dieses spannende projekt definiert bei
dem unter anderem auch die künstliche
intelligenz eine entscheidende rolle
spielen soll wie genau will man in
diesem projekt nach außerirdischem leben
fanden wie unterscheidet es sich von
anderen projekten und wie schätzt die
wissenschafts community die chance ein
tatsächlich außerirdisches leben zu
identifizieren alle spannenden antworten
auf diese fragen und noch viel mehr
jetzt bei pixum science and future
professor abram loeb ist in der
wissenschaftsgemeinde umstritten seit
zehn jahren leitet er den fachbereich
astronomie an der university harvard und
hat bereits mehr als 700
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung
verfasst zudem ist er auch teil des
forschungsprojektes breakthrough star
schott bei den forschungssatelliten in
das der sonne nächstgelegene nachbar
sternsystem alpha centauri geschickt
werden sollen immer wieder hatte er auf
sich aufmerksam gemacht als es um den
interstellaren kometen um uhr ging hier
hatte legt die vermutung aufgestellt
dass dieser nicht natürlichen ursprungs
ist stattdessen handelt es sich bei
diesem objekt seiner meinung nach um
eine technik die von einer
außerirdischen lebensform stand und das
hat er nicht nur bei uns im interview
sondern auch inzwischen in buchform
gemacht im oktober 2017 war der
interstellare besucher oben nur
aufgetaucht ein besucher also aus einem
anderen sternensystem entdeckt mit der
hilfe des pan stars teleskops zuerst
ordneten die fachleute dieses objekt das
sich bereits wieder auf dem weg zurück
in den interstellaren raum befand als
komet ein später dann aber als asteroid
getauft wurde er dann ganz offiziell auf
1 2017 u1 humor und war somit eine echte
premiere und absolute sensation das
erste objekt das unter diese neue
terminologie für interstellar rastenfeld
für manche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wie beispielsweise eben
auch abraham loeb ist der name des
mysteriösen objekts programm die
bezeichnung humorist hawaiianisch und
mein einer art boten der aus der fernen
vergangenheit geschickt wurde um kontakt
mit uns aufzunehmen
in seinem aktuellen buch außerirdisch
intelligentes leben jenseits unseres
planeten schreibt abram löw dass es sich
bei diesem objekt um ein außerirdisches
raumschiff handelt das nach dem prinzip
eines sonnensegels durch den
interstellaren raum zu uns gereist kam
und das hat sich der harvard-professor
zum glück nicht einfach aus den fingern
gesaugt er hat für seine analyse alle
daten und fakten zur mon amour genauer
ins visier genommen er stützt sich vor
allem auf die beschleunigung des objekts
und die ungewöhnliche form beides kann
seiner meinung nach nur damit erklärt
werden dass es sich beim humor um ein
außerirdisches raumschiff handelt dazu
hatte er anfang diesen jahres 2021 in
einem interview gesagt wenn die einzige
möglichkeit die fakten über humor zu
erklären darin besteht sich etwas
vorzustellen dass wir noch nie gesehen
haben warum nicht über einen künstlichen
ursprung nachdenken ich habe ein segel
vorgeschlagen das licht reflektiert
genau wie ein segel auf einem boot das
durch die reflektion von luft partikeln
angeschoben wird philips meinung steht
also fest es muss sich um ein konstrukt
von außerirdischen gehandelt haben nur
diese theorie kann seiner meinung sowohl
die bahn als auch die form des objekts
erklären nach der ansicht von apple im
look ist es für unsere suche nach
zivilisation jenseits der erde wichtig
sich nicht weiter auf die signale ferner
intelligenzen zu konzentrieren
stattdessen sollten wir uns bei unserer
suche vielmehr auf hinterlassenschaften
wie etwa raumschiffe und sondern
konzentrieren um untergegangener
außerirdische kulturen zu entlarven
sollten wir seiner meinung nach also
vielmehr nach ihren relikten also quasi
ihrem müll ausschau halten dazu sagt der
frame loeb mal wie reporter die
mülltonnen von prominenten in hollywood
durchwühlen können wir anhand ihres
mülls etwas über ihr leben herausfinden
und damit sind wir auch gleich bar im
lyz neuestem shit das galileo-projekt
ein netzwerk basierte teleskope soll
genutzt werden um nach interstellaren
objekten die möglicherweise
außerirdischer natur sind zu suchen
konkret soll nach außerirdischen
raumschiffen in der erdumlaufbahn wie
auch nach fluggeräten in unserer
atmosphäre gesucht werden ein deutlicher
unterschied also zum see projekt die
abkürzung für search for
extraterrestrial intelligence das
bereits vor 81 jahren und 60 gegründet
wurde hier suchen die fachleute nach
signalen von außerirdischen das
galileo-projekt spezialisiert sich
dagegen auf physische gegenstände unter
anderem sollen ufo sichtung ansatzpunkte
für die suche seien erst kürzlich konnte
das us pentagon ja nicht ausschließen
dass es sich bei einigen ufo-sichtungen
um außerirdisches leben handeln könnte
wir hatten darüber bei pixum science im
future berichtet ihr unterlief findet
ihr das video aber auch das mysteriöse
interstellare objekt humor soll nun noch
einmal genauer ins visier genommen
werden konkret wurden drei ziele
definiert die das galileo projekt
verfolgen soll zum einen sollen neue
teleskope errichtet werden die den
luftraum gezielt überwachen so erhoffen
sich löw und sein team neues
datenmaterial und vor allem auch
hochauflösende fotos von
unidentifizierten phänomen in der luft
dazu kommt dann die suche nach inters
stelle an objekten wie moore seien diese
erst erspäht bekämen die astrophysikerin
und astrophysiker mehr zeit um diese
genauer zu analysieren frühzeitig soll
also erkannt werden wenn und wann sich
solche interstellaren objekte der erde
nähern das pan stars teleskop auf hawaii
und das acht meter telescope in chile
das derzeit noch gebaut wird könnten
dafür eingesetzt werden dann wäre sogar
möglich sonden zu diesen objekten zu
schicken um diese genauer ins visier zu
nehmen dazu sagt der mitbegründer des
galileo projekts frank glaubt ihm wir
sollten beim nächsten mal viel früher
viel bessere daten haben und vielleicht
auf den objekten landen oder ihnen sehr
sehr nahe kommen des weiteren soll eben
galileo projekt auch künstliche
intelligenz eingesetzt werden und zwar
um nach künstlichen satelliten von einem
meter durchmesser oder weniger zu suchen
bei der auswertung soll dann eine ki
helfen die finanzierung des projekts
galileo ist übrigens auch eine spannende
sache nachdem er beim loeb anfang des
jahres sein buch veröffentlicht hatte
hatten sich wohl einige personen
unaufgefordert bei ihm gemeldet diese
hatten dem astrophysiker eine
finanzierung seiner forschung angeboten
mehrere leute hatten dann am ende
gespendet und mit diesen 175 millionen
dollar kann apple löw seine pläne
aufnehmen und vorantreiben so hatte er
sich dann auf die suche gemacht nach
weiteren wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die mitmachen wollen
doch nicht alle waren begeistert von
seinen plänen wie er sagt doch genau in
diese richtung geht seinen appell die
wissenschaftsgemeinschaft sollte
aufgeschlossen sein so kommen wir voran
fügte hinzu dass das galileo team plant
seine daten frei zu veröffentlichen um
andere wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen zu ermutigen sich
ebenfalls an der suche zu beteiligen aus
der wissenschafts community gab es
beides kritik und zustimmung in einem
kommentar hatte beispielsweise der
britische astronom alan für zimmerns die
frage aufgeworfen was das projekt zu der
bereits existierenden forschungen
hinzufügen können der us physiker
empfang dagegen befürwortet das
galileo-projekt er hält es für legitim
zu untersuchen ob die erde in ihrer
geschichte möglicherweise bereits von
außerirdischen besucht worden ist zitat
es ist eine vernünftige frage ob die
erde in ihrer geschichte besucht wurde
wenn wir auch nahe gelegenen exoplaneten
offensichtliche lebenszeichen entdecken
würden würden wir sollten schicken die
suche nach artefakten ist ein sinnvoller
ansatz wir sollten auf jeden fall bereit
sein für das nächste humor wir werden
viel über diese dinge lernen was immer
sie sind offiziell als könnte
außerirdisches leben sein usa kann ufos
nicht erklären anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran